when I opened my laptop I want to do one
thing get stuff done you know what makes
that hard this and this yeah
I'm partially at fault I have an app
opening problem and I'm a website tab
order but last week I decided to upgrade
my two-year-old MacBook Air to Apple's
latest Mac OS 10 El Capitan and I've
noticed an improvement to my computer
speed and my see look how fast I can
count to 100 okay no you won't
experience any crazy side effects like
that but what you can expect is a real
productivity increase from the free
upgrade coming on September 30th hold up
Apple's new software is gonna make my
computer faster it usually makes it
slower I was skeptical too but the
results they speak for themselves
Apple's Photos app launched two times
faster opening 20 photos in the preview
app was 2 times faster and even opening
word was a half a second faster jumping
between apps also felt noticeably
quicker though I couldn't time that in
my usual stopwatch tests overall my air
just felt speedier and it didn't take a
hit on battery life either I can't
promise zero slowdowns if your computer
is still limping along it could be that
you're low on storage or a ram or a
handful of other things but when you do
experience those slowdowns at least
there's this pretty new spinning rainbow
ball to look at those speed increases
will save some time but the new
multitasking tricks those have made the
real difference in my day to day pull
down on the green circle and drag the
window to one side of the screen and you
can put another app side by side Apple
took this one straight out of
microsoft's playbook and the way windows
implements it is still easier speaking
of now Mission Control instead of
grouping windows by app shows you all
your open windows spread out and the new
bar along the top tells you what apps
are on what screens plus if you lose
track of your cursor in all that mess
just shake it and it gets bigger the
cursors are coming for us
ok yes this is kind of ridiculous but
the trick is really useful there was one
thing that also sped up my used in the
last week I decided to do the
unthinkable
use safari instead of Chrome
Chrome has always been a serious
resource hog on a Mac but Safari hasn't
been worth using because it lacked
features not anymore
you can now pin sites and mute noisy
pages right from the tabs plus the new
spotlight lets you search the web and
your Mac and natural language it's
helpful but it could be smarter and Siri
she's still m.i.a that leaves a gaping
hole compared to Cortana on Windows 10
it's currently 82 and brainy still I'll
excuse some of the missing features this
year because you're getting stuff done
and staying clear of this guy how much
do the bells and whistles really matter